straight ahead on law and crime daily
nfl player richard sherman is released
from jail without bail
the new video showing him allegedly
trying to force his way
in to his in-laws home
after 18 years convicted white killer
scott peterson
will get a new day in court to see if he
deserves a new trial
the allegations of juror misconduct he
has
the right to 12 independent jurors
why did robert durst want to change his
will right before his trial started
the millions the real estate heir now
wants to leave to witness his called
to testify against him plus is mark
redwine guilty of the murder of his 13
year old son
jury verdict count number one murder in
the second degree
lead the jury law on crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
pro footballer richard sherman is out of
jail he's due back in court
for misdemeanor charges as new
surveillance footage shows him trying to
force his way
into his in-laws home
in surveillance video released by the
redmond police department
former seattle seahawks player richard
sherman is seen trying to open the front
door
to his in-laws home sherman was arrested
early wednesday in kings county his wife
called 9-1-1
saying her husband was drunk and
belligerent and threatened suicide
richard no he's going through a really
bad depression he's on anti-depressants
he drank
he was threatening to kill himself
sherman was due in court on thursday
but his attorneys waived his first
appearance he's facing five misdemeanor
charges
criminal trespass malicious mischief
resisting arrest
and driving under the influence he was
originally booked on a felony charge of
burglary domestic violence
but that was dropped prosecutors
requested sherman's bail to be set at
ten thousand dollars
the judge said sherman is a pillar in
the community a business owner
husband and father sherman was released
without bail
on a promise to return to court
joining us today is civil rights
attorney katie smith and terry austin
katie i've heard of people trying to
break out of their in-laws but never
in any guess why the burglary the only
felony charge was dropped
you're right brian i believe it's
because usually with the burglary there
needs to be some sort of intent
that you try to go in to commit a crime
particularly theft and here especially
since he kept saying
come out i don't know that he
necessarily was trying to go in or there
wasn't evidence that he was trying to go
in to take anything
so i think that's why they rather
prudently got rid of the charge that
would likely not stick
makes sense now terry sherman's wife is
standing behind him
giving a glimpse of what may be
happening behind the scene what do we
know so far
that may be able to help his case you
know i think there are a number of
factors brian that could possibly help
his case first of all
no one was injured and that's important
and i haven't seen any record of any
prior arrest so if that's the case
that's going to play a factor as well
and one of the other big
issues is he has started this richard
sherman
family foundation and he gives back to
the community
for children in low-income areas for
educational purposes so
i actually think that's going to help as
well and his wife as you said
is supporting him they have two young
children i think all
in all if all of this is based on recent
mental illness
i think all of that is going to play
into what charges may eventually be
dropped and what charges
might be kept yeah in many cases like
this a person who is an
emotionally distressed person as they
may designate them on edp
may not go to criminal court but may go
to a mental health court where services
or aid is given to a person
especially for low level charges such as
this we'll keep you updated on the
richard sherman case as it progresses
thank you both turning now to other top
legal news making headlines
a jury found the capital gazette shooter
criminally responsible
rejecting the insanity defense for the
mass killing
jared ramos pled guilty to 23 charges
stemming from the june 28
2018 shooting that left five people dead
inside the newspaper's building
investigators believe ramos was out for
revenge and spent years planning the
attack
defense attorneys claimed ramos was
insane for years before the attack
and remained so to this day but the jury
unanimously
rejected that claim prosecutors are
asking for him to receive
five life sentences in california
prosecutors are continuing to present
their case against robert durst and have
a jailhouse phone call
on the real estate air wanting to leave
millions to witnesses
called to testify against him
just months before the start of his
trial last year durst is heard in a
phone call to his second wife
saying that if she dies before him he
would want his money split between
several of his friends
prosecutors have called those witnesses
to the stand asking about allegations he
murdered his best friend susan berman
durst cut ties with his family and the
new york real estate company
the durst organization and a 65 million
deal
in 2006. in this 2021 call
durst says he would like 5 million
dollars to go to his friend
susan giordano prosecutors say durst has
given her 350
000 dollars and promised to make sure
she's set for life
is it your testimony that the first time
that you ever heard
mr durst's to
leave you five million dollars of
contingent beneficiary
was playing this call today you never
heard that before
you never were aware of that information
no you and mr durst never had any
discussion
no let's bring back civil rights
attorney katie smith and co-host terry
austin to discuss
durst's will terry i've heard of money
can't buy happiness but it seems to be
able to buy loyalty
how well is lewin proving that point in
the trial
oh no question loon is proving that
point because
apparently money can buy you loyalty his
friends are all people who will say and
do anything
for him and susan giordano if she
already received
several hundred thousand dollars and
she's going to get five million she will
be
set for life and we know already that
the testimony of
other witnesses gene clark we have emily
and stuart altman we have douglas oliver
all of these individuals
have come on the stand lewin has spent
hours
with each of them showing exactly how
loyal they
are and what they expect to get back in
return from durst so
apparently money can buy you loyalty i
mean katie there's so many signs of this
kind of loyalty
happening between the little waves or
the fist bumps
and these uh witnesses seem to be the
money they seem to be getting sorry is
there any doubt this is hush money for
at least something oh brian it just
looks terrible right and
that is being made evidently clear you
know to this idea about money can't buy
you happiness i was talking to someone
the other day and they said well those
people have never been bailed out
remember no matter how much it is
usually money
is worth less than their freedom and
it's obvious that he's willing to pay
whether
he needs to to try to get off all right
as the testimony continues there in the
robert durst case make sure to check it
out on law and crime as we give you
capital gavel coverage
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily a verdict in the trial of a
colorado man
charged with murdering his 13 year old
son first
scott peterson to get his day in court
again the wife killer now getting a
hearing
to see if you'll get a new trial
everything you need to know next
welcome back scott peterson the man
convicted of killing his wife and unborn
son
will be getting hearing on a claim of
juror misconduct
law and crimes angina levy is here to
tell us what the judge is saying about
her decision to hold a hearing
brian scott peterson has been arguing
for some time that a woman
lied to get onto the jury and that he
deserves a new trial because of it
lacey peterson was eight months pregnant
when she vanished on christmas eve in
2002.
scott peterson has maintained he didn't
kill his wife and
unborn son but a jury found him guilty
peterson's attorneys have called one
juror rachelle nice a stealth juror
they say she lied about being a part of
a lawsuit by not disclosing she sought a
restraining order against her
boyfriend's ex
and to being a victim of domestic
violence while she was pregnant in 2001.
in court documents nice who was
nicknamed strawberry shortcake during
the trial
stated she did not think the restraining
order was a lawsuit
and did not call police or consider
herself a victim in the 2001 incident
with her boyfriend
we feel like there are a number of
things that
when you look at the totality of
everything that happened
it demonstrates that this one juror in
fact was
prejudiced coming into the jury
deliberations that she did in fact lie
about
to get on the jury judge ann christine
mizullo wrote in an order the facts in
the case are in dispute and will require
an evidentiary hearing
judge masulo also ordered prosecutors to
formally admit or deny peterson's claims
about nice
peterson juror mike belmessieri said
nice had a strong opinion about the case
when she was brought in as an alternate
juror
but doesn't believe she tainted
deliberations
being a woman and a mother why would
that opinion not be a strong opinion
she didn't in any way uh influence
anyone
and uh with her with her with her
position
meanwhile peterson's team feels good
about the chances of getting a new trial
we feel very strongly that inevitably
the truth is going to come out on this
case
i spoke with rachelle niece's lawyer
jeff carr told me that the district
attorney will be issuing a subpoena to
have rochelle niece testify
at that hearing a date for that hearing
will be
set at another hearing later in august
brian thanks angela back with us as
civil rights attorney katie smith and
terry austin
terry what is it that the defense has to
prove to show jury misconduct
it's not easy brian there are a number
of forms of jury misconduct obviously if
you bring in outside evidence or if you
go to the scene or if you communicate
about the case
but this dishonesty about a fact during
voir dire
is what they are claiming here in this
case and in order to prove that
they are going to have to ask the juror
about her understanding
about her prior experience and the judge
is going to want to determine whether or
not the jury was
actually tainted during the deliberation
so
it would have to have an effect on the
ultimate outcome
of the case and frankly it's a very
serious issue and she could be held in
contempt of court
all right so that's the game plan there
katie but do you see a winning argument
for the prosecution that there was no
jury misconduct i think it really goes
down to this evidentiary hearing because
obviously
the prosecution and the witness are
saying that this was just a mistake of
fact
not every misrepresentation is
intentional or rises to the level of
misconduct it would have to have been
number one some level of intent um for
example
disobedience to instructions
inappropriate communications
things that have more of an intentional
intentional nature and then secondarily
it actually
do actually affect the proceeding if she
was fair from then on out
it really doesn't have that much of an
effect so they have some hurdles to get
over
absolutely of course weighing the
evidence itself and the trial to see
whether or not this is what many would
call harmless error
or in fact an error that needs a new
trial anjanette
has the judge requested more information
from the defense attorneys
actually she has she requested two
copies
of basically the case file the trial
transcripts the exhibits
everything she wants one for her
chambers in san francisco and then
another copy to keep at the san mateo
county courthouse where all of these
proceedings
are being held she was brought in to
preside over this case
especially and she wants an electronic
copy of all of those items too
so she is looking to really dig into
this case and get to the bottom of all
of the facts and what went on
it looks like that's just the plan here
the judge wanting more information from
the defense a hearing about to be put on
of course we'll get to the bottom of
this in the california versus scott
peterson case
thank you everyone for contributing will
continue to keep eyes on this case
as it develops coming up on law and
crime daily what a bunch of retired law
enforcement officers are doing on social
media
plus the 13 year old missing after a
trip to colorado
his father on trial for murder will a
jury believe mark redwine killed his son
or did dylan disappear on his own our
legal analysis
ahead
[Music]
welcome back mike the cop is a police
officer turned social media influencer
and he's sharing a glass with our own
sean stix-larkin
on both of their returns to civilian
life in the latest episode of the
podcast
cocktails i'm kind of scared that you're
in here
no all seriousness listen man for
anybody that's uh you know law
enforcement man i'm all behind it man i
don't care people are
ideas for tv shows doing books uh a
scripted show you know
podcasts whatever it is man there's room
for everybody man just uh it's awesome
to see
cops former cops all that stuff it's a
different world than i think i started
writing a blog back in like 2014 and
felt like an island and now there's so
so much of a law enforcement
presence on social media it's really
cool man yeah it is so uh
let's cheers to you first of all man
thanks for being on here cheers to you
you know taking cheers walking away from
the profession as well or retiring as i
guess we call
three men were arrested in texas for a
kidnapping and murder
of a man in 2016. but as jesse weber
the host of the terry's tv series prime
crime tells us
don't believe everything you hear
hey there brian yeah this story is
unique we have a reported home invasion
with a young mother named samantha
wolford explaining how she and her
husband were attacked
in fact the assailants kidnapped her
husband now it becomes a race
to find him and through samantha's
account we get clues
as to what happened and as far as you
yourself you didn't have any involvement
in this whatsoever
you didn't you heard he didn't get into
a fight no things didn't get out of hand
you didn't shoot him you didn't stab him
you didn't hit him with a bag
no way but as we carefully review her
interrogation and the responding
officer's body cam footage
where this case leads is absolutely
shocking
tune in to law and crime
more make sure to check out jesse weber
on prime crime thank you jesse
when we come back the deliberations keep
us all on the edge of our seats
after weeks of the trial which side will
the jury believe in colorado versus mark
redline
the verdict next
jury verdict count number one murder in
the second degree
we the jury find the defendant mark
rightlang
guilty of count number one murder in the
second degree
jury verdict account number two child
abuse
we the jury find the defendant mark
redwine
guilty of count two child abuse
after about six hours of deliberation a
colorado jury found mark redwine guilty
in the murder of his 13 year old son
redwine is accused of killing his son
dylan redwine prosecutors say the boy
confronted red wine
after seeing photos of his father
dressed in women's lingerie
and eating feces dylan vanished on
thanksgiving weekend in 2012
while on a court mandated trip to his
father's but
redwine maintains his innocence claiming
that wild animals could have killed the
boy
after he ran away the prosecutors of the
lolata county
sheriff's department federal bureau of
investigation kara bureau of
investigation
national forest service cannot tell you
after nine years what happened because
they don't know
if they don't know
you don't know
you may not like the pictures of mr
redwine
and you may not approve of the way he
handled himself during the search first
zone
you may not approve the way he handles
himself during the divorce
you may not prove a lot of things he
does
but if they don't know what happened
you don't know what happened if you
don't know what happened
regardless of your opinions of the
defendant
and having supported himself while his
son was missing
and dead you must return
verdicts of not guilty
in the rebuttal prosecutors say mark
redwine's action proved he is guilty
of the second degree murder of his son
mark redline was the last person seen
with dylan mark redwater was the last
person with dylan
when he was heard from by anybody in the
universe
he had the opportunity and the reason to
hurt dylan
whether it's the poop pictures whether
it's a fight they're having
an argument he took his head dylan's
head
with enough force to kill him and made
cuts
into his bone he killed dylan
he'll tell your loved one he's also
guilty because he had dylan's blood
in his house and there was dna down
there
and he had the smell of a human
body a human remains dog alerted
on multiple spots in the same room where
they were sitting that same room that i
just talked about where there was blood
sound where there was tension and anger
and they were rough housing
and the smell of human remains in his
truck
katie the jury wanted the transcripts of
agent gerson
but when they couldn't get it they came
back with a verdict
does that tell you anything yeah brian
you know i see this a lot especially in
federal court where the jury wants maybe
a quick look at some of the testimony
but then they realize it's a lot bigger
deal because the testimony needs to be
located and read back
and a lot of times that's to resolve
some minor factual discrepancy
amongst the jurors what i understand
here is that
they had already had their minds decided
they didn't want to wait the whole
weekend
and come back on monday so they were
ready to call in the verdict which they
did
absolutely called it in as well pretty
quickly after about six hours of
deliberating
uh terry was this the verdict you were
expecting
and if so why do you think it took six
hours
you know i did expect a guilty verdict i
thought that the prosecution put on an
excellent case
they showed in fact that there was blood
dna they knew
that he was with mark before he passed
and it was the last person he was with
they showed the cuts on the skull they
showed that molly the dog
indicated they showed his cavalier
attitude so for all those reasons i was
expecting a guilty verdict but i was a
little bit concerned brian
because there could have been some doubt
as you heard the defense closing there
he was saying no one really knows what
happened and it was
all circumstantial so there could have
been one juror who held out
and of course you could get a mistrial
based on that and you wouldn't get a
guilty verdict because a guilty verdict
obviously has to be unanimous so
i was a little worried but i think it
took six hours
because they considered all of the
evidence and they came back
with a right result now terry appeals
you know the defense is going to make an
appeal for
any number of issues do you see any
issues that the defense may be
successful
upon appeal you know i think the judge
ran an excellent court i don't think he
let any evidence
in that should not have gotten in and i
don't think he
left anything out so i think they're not
going to have
any judicial error and i didn't see any
evidence of
you know jury misconduct either so i
think that on appeal we're going to have
solid grounds
i think obviously the defense is going
to have to try to appeal because
that's the right of the defendant but i
didn't see anything that stood out to me
here brian
all right thank you terry and katie
sentencing for mark redwine is sometime
in october where he faces up to 48 years
for the top count to murder in the
second degree also guilty of child abuse
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you